قرر الرئيس اليمني علي عبد الله صالح
الغاء زيارته الى واشنطن التي اعلن عنها
نهايه الشهر الماضي وقالت مصادر رسميه ان
الالغاء جاء استجابه لضغوط من كبار اعضاء
حزبه ياتي ذلك بينما تستمر المظاهرات في
اليمن مطالبه بمحاكمه صالح وعوانه بتهم
قتل المتظاهرين ورفضا لقانون منتظر يمنحه
الحصانه من الملاحقه القضائيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه من زاويتين ما
مدى تاثير بقاء الرئيس اليمني داخل البلاد
على حركه الثوار ومسيره حكومه الوفاق
والتحضير للانتخابات الرئاسيه
وهل مكانه اقامته بعد رئاسه يمثل معضله في
ظل المطالب المطالبه بمحاكمته في الداخل
وعدم وجود بلاد واضح له في الخارج
السلام عليكم
رئيس اليمني العدوله عن فكره السفر الى
الولايات المتحده والبقاء في البلاد حتى
موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه شهر المقبل صالح
قال من قبل ان يسافر ان هذا السفر ياتي
لتسهيل عمل الحكومه للتحضير الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والان يقول اعضاء حزبه ان بقائه
مهم لمنع الصراعات في البلاد قبل هذه
الانتخابات في غضون ذلك برزت العلن مسوده
وقانون يمنح الحصانه لصالح ومعاونيه
المدنيين والعسكريين الذين عملوا معه طوال
ثلاثه 33 عاما من اي ملاحقه قضائيا داخليا
او خارجيا بينما الثوار على موقفهم
المطالب بالمحاكمه
بين التنحي والمبادره والمحاكمه تزداد
المسافه اتساعا بين مطالب الثوار في
الشارع وبين الممكن تحقيقه منها الرئيس
اليمني لا يغادر البلاد الى الولايات
المتحده او الى غيرها في الوقت الراهن على
الاقل تبرر الحكومه هذا التراجع في قرار
السفر بحاجاتها الى بقاء صالح في هذه
المرحله الحساسه لدعم العمليه السياسيه
المرتقبه مع بدء الانتخابات المقرره في
الحادي والعشرين من الشهر القادم
الا انها لم توضح ماهيه هذا الدعم السياسي
علما بان بعض احزاب اللقاء المشترك اشترطت
عدم عوده المشمولين بقانون الحصانه
القضائيه ومن بينهم علي صالح الى الحياه
السياسيه غير ان صالح لم يشمل بعد بقانون
الحصانه لذا ارجع حسب ما قال مغادرته
البلاد الى حين حسم مساله الحصانه التي
تحول بحسب البند الثالث من المبادره
الخليجيه دون ملاحقته قضائيا بتهم كثيره
وعلى راسها القتل تباين المواقف السياسيه
بشان منح الحصانه للرئيس اثار جدلا داخليا
تجلى في فشل احزاب اللقاء المشترك في
اقناع الشارع حتى الان بتقبل منح الحصانه
لصالح واعوانه ولكن الشارع لا يهدا من
ثورته متشبثا باهم مطالبه التي تمزقت بين
صفقات سياسيه داخليه وخارجيه وظفت مخرجا
ينقذ الرئيس ماذا كنت تقف امامه الحكومه
مكتوفه الايدي فتحاول الخروج منه من تبني
مشروع قانون بديل عن قانون الحصانه يكون
متوازنا ويمكنها من الوفاء بالتزاماتها
المنصوص عليها في المبادره الخليجيه
واهمها اقرار قانون الحصانه تتقلص خيارات
الامن امام الرئيس علي صالح وسط توجس في
بعض الاوساط السياسيه الامريكيه من اي
يعرض منحه تاشيره الدخول اداره اوباما
الانتقادات شعبيه وسياسيه لاذعه على اعتاب
انتخابات رئاسيه هامه وفي ظل مواقف
اقليميه مبهمه من استضافته لم يعد هناك
متسع من الوقت امام صالح على ما يبدو لحسم
مشروع الحصانه
معنى في هذه الحلقه من صنعاء سلطان
الرداعي الناشط من شباب الثوره اليمنيه من
القاهره محمد ناجي علاوي القيادي وفي
اللقاء المشترك ومن صنعاء ينضم الينا عبر
الهاتف عبد الحفيظ النهاري نائب رئيس
الدائره الاعلاميه في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي
العام اهلا بضيوفنا الثلاثه لو بدانا
بالسيد عبد الحفيظ النهاري في صنعاء الى
اي مدار قرار الرئيس الغاء السفر والبقاء
مربك لحكومه ما زالت تتلمس طريقها
الحكومه وليس متعلقا بادائها على الاطلاق
اعتبار الاخ الماعب هو المشرف بحسب تفويض
التفويض الرئاسي وبحسب نصوص المبادره
الخليجيه وعليه
فان نائب الرئيس
والمعني باداره حكومه الوفاق والاشراف
عليها اما مساله الرئيس فكانت مرتبطه
بما نتج عن اللقاء التشاوري للقيادات في
المؤتمر الشعبيه العام والتي رات امراض
ضروره
لسفره وان بقائه مهم بحسب
يعني بحسب رغبه القاعده الجماهيريه
العريضه للمؤتمر الشعبي العام الذين
يحددون ان يبقى الرئيس الى جانبهم في مثل
هذه الاستحقاقات الهامه هل
هو ضغط حزبي ام ربما رغبه من الرئيس غلفت
حزبيا
السلام عليكم سيدي بصراحه انا اعتذر هذا
الامر غادر
خرج من البلاد ام لم يخرج مناكفه سياسيه
اصلا نحن لا يهمنا ان يغادر البلاد بل
يهمنا الامر الصحيح والواضح والذي نباركه
به دائما الشباب في جميع الساحات في جميع
الميادين في جميع المسيرات نطالب بمحاكمته
نقول لعلي صالح رغم ان الامر في دلاليتين
الدلاله الاولى ليعلم العالم اجمع بان هذا
الرجل كاذب ناقص لكل عدى وكاذب من قال
يوما ان الثعلب دينا اصلا
الدلاله الثانيه ان الطلب هذه المره اتى
من قيادات حزب كما ذكر النهاري هذا
النهاري وهذا في دلاله واضحه لانهم فزع
قادت حزبه عندما تسارع موظفي المؤسسات
عندما تسارع في التوجيه المعنوي في كليه
الطيران في جميع المرافق الحكوميه تسارع
الموظفون تسارع
ابناء هذا الشعب الى كنز جميع بقايا
وزباله هذا النظام التي ربضبت على صدر هذا
الشعب ثلاثه عبود عندها هربوا الى كبيرهم
الذي علمهم السحر يستنجدون به الى من
تتركنا لانهم يعرفوا بان الشعب لم يقبلهم
ابدا ان يبدوا اقول بصراحه
انهم يقودوا علي عبد الله صالح بهذه
الطريقه الى نهايه القذافي نحن علي صالح
لم نظل لغادر لم نقل خرجنا بدايه التوراه
قلنا رحل كما رحلت زين العابدين قتل قلنا
خياره مثل حسن مبارك ارتكب مجازر واحرق في
تعب قلنا بل اخترت طريق القذافي وحتما نحن
على يقين بان هذه نهايته الامر الذي يهمنا
انه لابد من محاكمته لابد من محاكمه جميع
اركانه ولا يهمنا هذه المناكفات السياسيه
بالنسبه للرئيس علي عبد الله صالح القضيه
ليست البقاء فقط وهنا اسال السيد محمد
ناجي اعلاه في القاهره ليس فقط البقاء
وانما حسب التصريحات المسؤولين اليمنيين
هو سيقود الحمله الانتخابيه الرئاسيه
للرئيس الجديد هل هذا يبدو مقنعا بالنسبه
بالنسبه لكم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير عليكم
جميعا وعلى
الساده المشاهدين اولا اسمي محمد ناجي
علاوه وليس علاوي صلحتها انا صلحتها في
الفتره اللي انت ما سمعتش فيها سيد علاوي
تفضل
انا لم اسمع نعم
حقيقه انا استغرب القول بوجود حمله
انتخابيه حمله انتخابيه على ماذا الرجل
نازل كمرشح وحيد وفقا للمبادره
يعني بمعنى بان المساله استفتاء يحصل على
اي اصوات يمكن ان ينجح بها رغم مالي كرجل
قانون من ملاحظات حول مساله المرشح الوحيد
والذي ايضا يتعللون بانه وفقا للدستور
الذي يجري خارج الدستور تماما باعتبار ان
المبادره الخليجيه صارت اعلانا دستوريا
لها احكامها الخاصه وبالتالي فلا علاقه
لدستور الجمهوريه اليمنيه بهذا الامر
بالتالي لا توجد اي حمله انتخابيه من
المنافس لعبد ربه هادي منصور هادي حتى
يقود صالح حمله انتخابيه له وسيكون
بالتاكيد لو كان هناك منافسا سيكون اسوا
قائد حمله انتخابيه لانه محروق شعبيا
والرجل مطلوب وراسه كيف يكون مطلب راسه
ومطلوب محاكمته ويقود حمله نظر عن كلام
الاخ عبد الحفيظ النهاري بانه يتمتع
بقاعده الشعبيه عريضه انا ندري من اين
ياتي بهذا القول
مساله يعني اذا كان سؤال في حدود الحمله
الانتخابيه فلا توجد اصلا انتخابات بهذا
المعنى حتى يقودها صالح وكما قلت سيكون
قائدا سيئا بالتاكيد لانه وجه غير مقبول
هذا جانب الجانب الثاني هناك سؤال انا
ارجو استاذ محمد ان تطرحه على نفسك وعلى
الجميع اي انتخابات ستجري ومناطق عديده
محافظات
بيد مس لم يعترفوا بالمبادره الحوثي بصعده
والحراك في الجنوب والحاله الامنيه هل
سيعقد صالح صفقه مع هؤلاء للسماح باجراء
انتخابات هذه ذكر المسلحين على ذكر
المسلحين سيد علاوي على ذكر المسلحين هناك
اتهامات من قبل السيد الاحمر بان هناك
ايضا تدفق رهيب للسلاح من قبل الرئيس
واعوانه على مجموعات معينه هذا على كل
كالتهام نريد ان نسال السيد النهاري اولا
كان لديه تعقيب سريع على ما قيل لحد الان
وثانيا قيل بان الرئيس لم يكن يشا ان
يغادر الا بضمانات بعد ان ضمن لنفسها
الحسانه طالما هذه الحسانه متعثره لم يشاء
ان يجازف
عزيزي نحن الان نتحدث
بلغه المبادره الخليجيه
واليتها التنفيذيه واي حديث خارج النصوص
ومفاهيم وتفضيلات المبادره لا طائله منه
وانما يقصد به تضييع الوقت
وعرقله انجاز الاستحقاقات المترتبه على
المبادره التي اصبحت اماميه ولم تعد
خليجيه وهي اصبحت برعايه المجتمع الدولي
كله ولكن للتوضيح اسمح لي فقط سيد النهاري
للتوضيح المعرضون يقولون هناك المبادره
الخليجيه وهناك اليه تنفيذها والحديث عن
الحصانه لم يكن بهذا التفصيل حتى ان مجلس
الامن الدولي لم يشير اليها بهذا المعنى
الدقيق يعني
نعم
مجلس الامن الدولي لم يشر الى موضوع
الحصانه بهذا المعنى الدقيق لان هناك
المبادره الخليجيه وهناك اليات تنفيذها
كما يقول المعارضون نص المبادره ونص
الاليه اشار
بشكل دقيق
وحصيب
ومؤكد مؤكدها ايضا السفير الامريكي وسفراء
الدول الدائمه العضويه وهو تاكيد لمفهومهم
لهذا النصب وهو وهذا ليس عمل
ليس امل جديد بل هو متسق مع كثير من
التجارب
المماثله التي حدثت في افريقيا وحدثت في
امريكا اللاتينيه وحدثت في دول كثيره عانت
من الصراعات الاهليه او كانت في طريقها
الى الصراعات الاهليه وفي اطار وعنوان
العداله الانتقاليه التي تتوفى السلم
الاجتماعي وازاله قيم
ولغه الثار والانتقام والتحول الى البناء
الى البناء الانتقالي الديمقراطي السلمي
على وحده وسلامه وتماسك البلاد وتحقيق
مستوى الاصلاح والتغيير المطلوب الذي
تنشده كل الفئات المجتمع بما فيها الشباب
اذا نحن بصدد هذه الاهداف الكبرى التي لا
يمكن ان تقف عند مسائل صغيره لانه لو
وقفنا دائما امام المسائل الجزئيه فان اين
اين
سنضع جريمه مسجد الرئاسه ممن يدعون الان
ويتشدقون
بحقوق الانسان او بمحاكمه صالح
يعني لتوضيح يعني للتوضيح حتى لا تكون
هناك مقارنات في غير محلها من قاموا
بمحاوله اغتيال الرئيس اوقفوا ويجري
التحقيق معهم وسيعرضون على القضاء اذا
القضيه ليست في وارد المقارنه المناسبه
على كل موضوع المحاكمه او الحصانه سنتوقف
عندها اكثر لا سيما من وجهه نظر اين سيتجه
الرئيس وملا
ذ الامن ان صح التعبير في ضوء هذه
المسجلات التي تجري في اليمن لنا عوده بعد
قليل نرجو ان تبقى معنا
انا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الغاز زياره
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح الى الولايات
المتحده وهذا الجدل الدائر حاليا في اليمن
حول موضوع الحصانه التي يفترض ان يتمتع
بها وفق المبادره الخليجيه سيد سلطان
الرداعي
لماذا انتم
تتوقفون كثيرا عند موضوع الحصانه لان مثلا
الحصانه ليست مساله جيد جديده مثلما اشار
السيد النهار في بعض التسويات وهناك ايضا
مثلا سابقه في تونس الفصل 41 من الدستور
عندما كان بن علي في الحكم نص على حصانه
قضائيه اثناء ممارسه الحكم وبعد ترك الحكم
ولكن الان انظر بن علي اين هو موجود لماذا
لا تتركون القضيه تتفاعل تدريجيا دون ان
تجعلوا منها قضيه مركزيه
يا سيدي دعني
الاستاذ يعني ارجع الاستاذ النهاري
الاستاذ النهاري يدعي بان المبادره اصبحت
اماميه
اقول بصراحه مثال الامم
للاسف ذهب صوت سيد سلطان الرداعي ننتقل
محمد ناجي علاوي واضحه المره هذه سيد
علاوي اطرح عليك نفس السؤال موضوع الحصانه
بالنسبه لكم انتم دخلتم فيه كتسويه هل
تعتقد بانه الان اصبح مركزيا بدرجه يمكن
ان يربك هذه التسويه بشكل كامل
اذا انتهيت لاني لم اسمع بقيه الصوت
بقيه الحديث اقول بان اعود لكلام الاستاذ
عبد الحفيظ مثل ما قال سلطان
فاؤكد على ما اتى في حديثه من ان
العداله الانتقاليه التي يفترض ان تحكم
يعني فتره المصالحه
يفترض فيها او ما يجب ان تتضمنه مبادئ على
الانتقاليه ان
يجبر ضرر المصابين والشهداء
وتعويضات الاضرار وان يكون هذا القانون
شامل لهذا وان يشمل حرمانا سياسيا
ومن قاموا بهذا العمل ومن يطلبون الحصانه
والا يمارسون وظيفه عامه لفتره معينه والا
يمارسون عملا سياسيا وهذا ما حصل فعلا في
امريكا اللاتينيه وما حصل في بعض البلدان
التي
نهجت نهج المصالح العامه والعداله
الانتقاليه في الحاله هو الحاله اليمنيه
في الحاله اليمنيه هناك اصرار على الحصانه
وعلى العوده للحياه السياسيه اليس كذلك
لا لا يجتمعان شخص يقر بانه اعفوني مما
عملت سامحوني انني قتلت سامحوني انني نهبت
سامحوني انني دمرت ثم يبقى مدمرا وقاتلا
وممسكا للامام السلطه كبير هذا مبادر عدا
الانتقاليه التي نصت عليها ايضا نص عليها
الامن مقتضاه ان يكون هذا قانون للمصالحه
العامه يجبر الضرر يحرم من تشملهم الحصانه
من حق تولي العامه يعزلهم فورا من مواقعهم
يحرمهم من العمل السياسي لانهم قد افسدوا
ما مضى فلا يجب ان يفسدوا ما هو اتن وهو
ما يجري اليوم
فبالتالي الاخ عبد الحفيظ اتفق معه تماما
صارت امميه صارت على المجلس الامن ملزما
بالنسبه لنا القيت النصوص سد السوريه
بالتالي لم نكن بحاجه الى انتخابات رئيس
توافقي مؤقت قانون للمصالحه العامه مقتضى
هذا القانون ان يعزل كل من
يشمله هذا القانون بالعفو من المنصب الذي
يشغله وان يحرم من العمل السياسي لفتره
وان يجبر ضرر
المتضررين من الشهداء والجرحاء
والممتلكات التي اتلفت لو عدنا الى السيد
سلطان الربيعي حتى يكمل مداخلته تفضل
السيد داعي
اهلا سيدي اولا من ناحيه الحصان انا اقول
بصراحه
اعظم لا يملك لمن لا يستحق
واشكر استاذي محمد علاوي القانوني
القانوني المشترك الشهير واودي له هذا
الشال على الهواء مباشره من ناحيه علي
صالح
واركان نظامه لا شك انهم ارتكبوا هذه
الجريمه الحمقاء
وعقابهم واضح ولا يمكن ان يفروا منه ولا
ان يتنازل عنك لكن هناك لدينا الان هل يصح
من ناحيه جانونيه ان يكون مجموعه من
السياسيين بالتوقيع على الحصانه هل في هذه
الحاله نعتبرهم متواضعين على الجريمه ايضا
ما عقوبه النواب الذي سيصوت على هذه
الحصانه هل بالامكان ان نعتبرهم متسترين
على الجريمه هل بامكاننا الربح واريد
الجواب جانونيا اصلا هل بامكان رفع دعاوى
قضائيه على من وقع وعلى من سوت مجلس
النواب اخيرا اقول بصريح العباره الحصانه
نتحفظ عليها مثلا الحصانه واسعه مطاطيه
تقول لعلي صالح وكل من عمل معه خلال فتره
عملا من عمل هل تبادلوا الحصانه مع بعضهم
البعض هذا المثال محير هل
الجمل من الدرايه والنهب والقتل تسجل ضد
مجهول سيدي طلعت مجموعه من الاسئله الحيره
سيد
علاوي لو تكرمت باجابات مختصره حتى نعود
الى السيد عبد الحفيظ النهاري في نهايه
البرنامج
الاستاذ سلطان عدد من الاسئله الهامه صحيح
نعم الاستاذ سلطان طرح من الاسئله الهامه
الصحيح
ولكن اقول فعلا انه لا يجوز ان يكون في
القانون نص يعني مجهل مثل القول ومن عمل
معه من عمل معه كل موظفي الدوله وبالتالي
يفترض ان علي صالح افتراض عليه ان يقدم
قائمه باسماء من يرغب او من يريد ان
تشملهم هذه الحصانه
من ما هو حق عام وليس مما هو حق خاص
فاولئاء الدم لهم الحق ان يرفعوا الدعاء
ولا ولا يحصن صالح باي قانون ولا باي
دستور باعتبار اننا الحقوق الخاصه بالنسبه
لها لا يملك احدا حتى رحم الراح من جل
وعلا يعفوا فيما هو له ولكن لا يعفو في
يعني ما هو بصراحه
مجموعه من الاسئله الهامه ربما للاسف لا
يمكن ان نستعرضها بالكامل
هذه واحده هو غيرها لكن للاسف نريد ان
نسمع وجهه نظر سيدنا هاري في نهايه
البرنامج هل هناك الان اشكال بالنسبه
للرئيس علي عبد الله صالح لان البقاء في
اليمن مشكله ومغادرته ايضا مشكله
ليس هناك اي مشكله سواء بالعوده الى نصوص
المبادره واليتها التنفيذيه او بالعوده
الى الواقع السياسي او بالعوده الى علاقه
الشعب اليمني مع فخامه الاخ الرئيس الذي
يتمتع باغلبيه جماهيريه وفي صداقتها
المؤتمر الشعبيه العام وحسب التحرف الوطني
عندما نتحدث عن مساله
الحصانه فاننا نتحدث عن اطراف فاستخدمت
العنف اذا كان النظام قد استخدم العنف او
استخدم القوه والجيش والامن من اجل الحفاظ
على الامن العام وعلى المصالح العامه وعلى
السكينه العامه فماذا سنقول لاولئك الذين
استخدموا الادوات العنف خارج القانون شكرا
يعتبرون انفسهم انصار الثوره وهم متورطون
في جرائم خارج القانون وليس هناك ما
يخولهم لاستخدام العنف لا الو ولا قانونا
بينما كانت القوات المسلحه والامن على
امتداد فتره حكم علي عبد الله صالح او
شكرا لك شكرا لك سيدي عبد الحفيظ النهاري
نائب رئيس الدائره الاعلاميه في حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي العام الحاكم سابقا شكرا
لسلطان رداعي الناشط في من شباب الثوره
اليمنيه شكرا لمحمد ناجي علاوه القيادي في
اللقاء المشترك
في امان الله